so here's a before we get out of here a
little inside info I like to talk to the
audience before we start taping this
show and yesterday I met a wonderful
older man in the audience named Jim and
we're very lucky that the cameras were
rolling cuz something very fun happened
let's watch Jim and they you would come
on up here Jim
god you got one of those Jack LaLanne
firm hugs I love it
that's right new fan I'll win you over I
joined you to get a sense of so stay on
my mark see where it says the P there
that's for Peter that's my name so just
know right I'm here with you though I'll
do it together
right thank you thank you is that are
you gonna do it it's been a long time
since I learned to read I think back
when they were like witches are real
yeah there you go